[Musique]
François Lego visiblement heureux du
résultat qu'il a obtenu ce matin votre
de confiance qui surpasse le dernier
auquel il avait dû se soumettre en 2019
qui surpasse aussi celui qui avait
obtenu pointe saint-pierre-la-mondon des
délégués du PQ il y a quelques semaines
comment interpréter ce résultat voyons
voir ce qu'on pense mes collaborateurs
allez casse tonguette animateurs de midi
info et six premières Chantal Hébert et
chroniqueur au Toronto story au magazine
L'actualité Michel seoget est analyste
politique à La Presse et Radio-Canada
bon dimanche à vous trois bonjour
bonjour
l'effet 3e lien ça va venir le plomber
un peu tout le monde dure ça va être au
moins en haut des 90 mais là comment il
a réussi à dépasser le score de 2019
bon d'abord c'est clairement pas de la
base militante que va venir le moindre
couac sur François Legault c'est un
parti qui a été fondé du haut vers le
bas il est le père fondateur et les
militants clairement envoyer le message
que si un jour il veut quitter ce sera
de son plein gré ou alors ça ne sera pas
les militants qui vont qui vont les
mettre à la porte ça me semble assez
clair malgré les loups-voiements dans
certains dossiers assez importants
depuis quelques mois oui le troisième
lien l'immigration aussi depuis un an on
change de cap à toutes les trois ou
quatre mois on fait de la réflexion
ouverte on fait des déclarations qui
sont pas suivies de gestes ou d'action
alors l'immigration troisième lien
aurait pu donc peut-être éroder la
confiance d'un certain nombre de
militants délégués ça ne se fout pas le
cas on est clairement ici
davantage dans un parti discipliné ou
qui ne fait pas beaucoup de débats
choisissez l'angle que vous voulez qui
ressemble à celui de Jean Charret à
l'époque où il était premier ministre
militant libéral qui avait levé la main
pour avoir une enquête publique sur
l'industrie de la construction est
personne n'avait secondé sa motion on
est plus dans cette discipline là ou
dans le manque de débat que dans le
Parti québécois que François Legault a
connu du milieu des années 90 où
embrassait Lucien Bouchard allègrement
ou alors même de Robert Bourassa a fait
80 début 90 avec Mitch avec la langue un
certain Mario Dumont avec laquelle la
porte et tout donc on n'est pas du tout
dans le brassage actuellement à la CAQ
on est plutôt dans on estampille la
volonté de François Legault et de son
conseil des ministres d'aller quelque
part ok Michel ensuite Chantal Michel
j'avais plus l'impression de voir une
assemblée d'actionnaires une assemblée
de parti politique les actionnaires ils
veulent que l'accompagner marche et si
elle donne des bons résultats ben ils
sont très très contents de la direction
de la compagnie et c'est exactement ce
qu'on a vu dans le dans le mode de
confiance à Monsieur Lebeau il y a pas
beaucoup de débats de de fond dans cette
dans ce partie là dans les autres onglet
de la carte c'est pareil alors on veut
que ça marche et des choses comme le
troisième bien ça peut être un effet
dans la population et ça peut être très
grand effet auprès des membres de la CAB
qui eux disent hey faut que ça marche
bien on est avec Monsieur Legros j'ai
déjà dit c'est parti on pourrait
s'appeler le parti François Lego parce
que Chantal évidemment c'est les
militants il y a de la grande chez lapin
au sein de la population concernant le
troisième lien est-ce que ça veut dire
que monsieur Legault peut tourner la
page là aujourd'hui
avec ces militants là on est dans le
genre de congrès où on cherche ceux qui
ont qui sont trompés en votants qui ont
pas voter OUI à François Lebeau c'est là
qu'on est alors il est pas allé là il y
a pas passé la fin de semaine mais je me
souviens et ceux qui étaient là aussi de
Thomas manquer qui est sur sa propre job
John Turner à l'époque où Jean chrétiens
lui faisaient de l'ombrage avait passé
des congrès complets à tourner la page
mais là
il y a rien à tourner Michel a raison
lac c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
François Legault parce que pas besoin de
se préoccuper d'une fronde à l'intérieur
de son parti qui inévitablement finirait
par être une fronde au sein de son focus
mais c'est pas une si bonne nouvelle que
ça pour la carte dans le sens où ça veut
dire que la coalition Québec est encore
d'abord et avant tout le véhicule de
François Legault plutôt qu'un parti mais
en toute justice pour ceux qui couvrent
la scène fédérale ce qu'on en a vu
beaucoup des parties au pouvoir qui ont
des immenses des bonnes idées j'ai
regardé les images d'hier des débats sur
les résolutions il y avait un pas mal
plus grand nombre de délégués qui
participaient au moins
c'est votre là que ce qu'on a vu au
Congrès du Parti libéral fédéral la
semaine dernière effectivement c'est
vrai j'avais fait je me suis fait la
remarque aussi en garde à ça il y a bon
il y a tout ne peut pas être rose Michel
il doit y avoir des écueils 7 mètres
cette fin de semaine c'est la nomination
du juge mit Simon barre de Simon j'en ai
barrette qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
Monsieur Lego doit surveiller à partir
de maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il guette
quand on a 90 député puis qu'on a le
contrôle absolu de l'Assemblée nationale
et de la machine comme ils l'ont le
danger effectivement c'est que déjà
ça nécessairement nommer des
incompétents qui nomment des amis puis
que ces animaux sont peut-être
compétents et ça donne l'impression de
transparence il y a des il y a des
règles mais des manques de jugement
c'est pas obligé de nommer son meilleur
club les juges à la Cour du Québec il
l'a fait quand même monsieur qui s'en
défendre ça mène tout le gouvernement
sur la défensive monsieur Gérard konamé
aussi des des proches comme ça c'est pas
la première fois alors on va pour
commencer à se décharger là-dessus mais
il faut qu'il fasse attention à ça parce
que ça donne une impression que à la fin
on est là pour se servir plutôt pour
servir et ça ça peut à la longue avoir
un effet sur l'opinion publique c'est
pas un juge puis un membre de conseil
administration quelque part qui vont
faire cette cette perception là ça
devrait se reproduire beaucoup ça c'est
un ordre
et ensuite avec mes Chantal parce que il
y avait quand même réussi à l'éviter un
peu ce genre de problème là qui semble
toucher chaque gouvernement un moment ou
un autre durant le premier mandat on
n'avait pas vu ce genre d'épisode là
quand même où on les avait moins cherché
c'est sûr qu'un parti qui est au pouvoir
pour la deuxième fois dans une situation
avantageuse comme celui-là va découvrir
et ses membres aussi qu'ils ont de plus
en plus d'amis si on faisait une page
Facebook on verrait monter faire aussi
génieuse de gens qui se souviennent tout
à coup des liens d'amitié qui sont avec
l'un et l'autre et effectivement aussi
on peut pas décider que tout le monde
qu'on a connu est exclu de tout
pour tout le temps qu'on est au pouvoir
il y a une certaine absence de logique
là-dedans donc la façon de s'en prémunir
c'est effectivement de multiplier
l'obligation de se désister de certaines
discussions de déclarer son conflit
d'intérêt
au niveau de l'amitié mais de dire on va
exclure du coup tout le monde qu'on a
connu un chemin poésie ça me semble une
grande injustice pour les malheureux qui
ont été amies avec des gens qui
aujourd'hui sont ministres
depuis la commission Bastarache en 2011
sur la nomination des juges le Québec a
et de loin le processus le plus
rigoureux de nomination des juges peu
importe la province et même à Ottawa où
on a encore le goût de considérer le
pencheur politique du candidat ça c'est
ça c'est vu et encore récemment où on
vérifie qui était dans libéralisme la
base de données du Parti libéral par
exemple il y a pas de ça au Québec la
composition du comité de sélection est
extrêmement diversifiée rigoureux et
ceux donc qui le traversent avec un
examen ma foi assez compliqué réussit
s'asseoir jusqu'à la fin sont de très
bons candidats et donc le juge Gosselin
maintenant juge et certainement très
qualifié d'ailleurs personne ne remet ça
en question et il y a une raison pour
laquelle un ministre de la Justice ne
partage pas sa liste de nomination avec
ses collègues c'est pour éviter ce qui
s'est produit sous maître Bellemare
avant la commission bastarash ou le
Premier ministre bien ministre puis un
ami commence à dire ben moi dans ta
liste cette personne là je l'aime mieux
que l'autre alors la liste elle est
restreinte sous ministres ministre de la
c'est tout personne d'autre ne voit la
liste
par contre quand on arrive dans une
conciliation entre l'amitié aussi
étroite d'un candidat et
je suis d'accord avec Chantal peut-être
qu'on devrait maintenant donner un
dernier tour de vie ça se processus là
où on devrait peut-être pour des raisons
exceptionnelles dire quelqu'un d'autre
devait prendre la décision finale et là
je parle pas de quelqu'un on ne croiser
avec qui on a déjà plaidé parce que le
ministre de la Justice évidemment est
dans le milieu du droit depuis longtemps
qu'on connaît plein de gens mais quand
on a célébré le mariage de cette
personne là quand il a écrit notre
vignette dans l'album de finissant il y
a une proximité plus grande que la
normale et peut-être qu'on aurait dû
dire la décision finale revient au
Premier ministre ou à tel ministre et
moi je me recule la discussion c'est
peut-être le dernier tour de vis qui
reste pour des cas très exceptionnels
qui se présente rarement pour que là on
est vraiment un processus parfait et ça
s'est produit dans ce cas-ci ça veut pas
dire que tu es une mauvaise domination
ça veut peut-être dire qu'il faut encore
apprendre à donner peut-être une
dernière petite dernière petite tour de
de vis à ce processus
les comités qui désignent les juges qui
vont être soumis au ministre de la
justice c'est dans la composition du
comité dans le code de type du comité de
dire si vous connaissez quelqu'un vous
devez le déclarer ça pourrait ça
pourrait s'appliquer au ministre ça fait
pas un gros tour de vis mais ça sera une
garantie
on verra ce que ça va donner mais ça
fait passer une mauvaise fin de semaine
si moi j'en ai marre ça c'est sûr je
vous amène sur le terrain fédéral il y a
direction partielle qui s'en viennent
dans quatre circonscriptions au Canada
et là il y a déjà un candidat qui s'est
déclaré c'est quelqu'un qu'on connaît
bien je vais vous faire entendre sa
conférence de presse de vendredi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ou Manitoba Chantal qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire la candidature qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on surveille de cette
candidature là dans la parcelle de
partage de ce
en 2021 avec le vent du mouvement
anti-mesure sanitaire dans le dos
c'était la circonscription où une partie
de monsieur Bernier qui n'était pas
candidat dans cette circonscription mais
qui était candidat plutôt dans la bourse
a obtenu 22% des suffrages aujourd'hui
le vent est tombé il y a un nouveau chef
conservateur qui a fait des clins d'oeil
justement au mouvement anti-mesure
sanitaire le texte évidemment c'est
est-ce que monsieur Bernier a encore
autant de tirant d'eau ou plus ou est-ce
que l'élection de Pierre Poirier et le
style de Pierre poillière vont permettre
une fois pour toutes on parlait de
tourner la page aux parties conservateur
fédéral de tourner la page sur le bas de
page quand il était jusqu'à présent le
Parti populaire de Maxime Bernier alors
mettons là
mettons que le jour du vote il y a 30%
35% des électeurs qui votent pour Maxime
Bernier et sont partis ça serait une
extraordinairement mauvaise nouvelle
pour Pierre poi lièvre et ça ouvrirait
la porte à une série de problèmes mais à
l'inverse si Maxime Bernier fait moins
c'est sa troisième tentative il y a pas
eu aussi en basse sont partis va devenir
un bien moins gros nuage et un bien
moins gros pensée si bien pour le Parti
conservateur fédéral franchement tête du
côté de Michel pour la petite pour la
petite histoire le candidat du Parti
populaire du Canada va obtenir 22% des
votes au ferrailleurs la dernière fois
dans partage parce que vous surveillez
quoi vous
il est fait combiné de Bernier et de
quoi lièvre si il y a quand même un
virage à droite on peut discuter de
combien prononcer il était avec
l'arrivée de Monsieur poignet est-ce que
ça ça coupe les ailes de Maxime Bernier
ou si au contraire ça lui donne du vent
dans les voiles moi je suis pas sûr de
ça mais ça va vous permettre de juger ça
et si monsieur Bernier fait pas une très
bonne figure là c'est déjà un parti qui
est passé qui est pas très solide qui
est pas député au Parlement la question
c'est est-ce qu'il va continuer à
contrer parce que c'est un peu un test
pour monsieur Bernier avec Cyrus Paul
super son pari là-bas c'est un peu la
fin des haricots là pour le Parti
populaire du Canada c'est la meilleure
circonscription au pays selon les
résultats de 2021 ici donc le chef se
présente et ne fait pas mieux que les
22%. on se demande où à quel endroit ce
serait plus payant pour lui de se
présenter ou d'aller espérer avoir un
député donc il faut qu'il fasse mieux
que 22% ce qui peut gagner j'en doute la
situation des conservateurs
un certain appel pour le Parti populaire
du Canada mais il y a aussi un certain
appel pour Pierre pollière domine dans
les sondages qui est très populaire
auprès de sa base alors les
circonstances vont être difficiles pour
lui
les électeurs de portage les gars vont
devoir se demander qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent le plus refaire la bataille des
mesures sanitaires et autres ou se
débarrasser du Justin Trudeau et si la
question de l'une c'est pour les
électeurs conservateurs on s'entend ce
débarrasser du Justin Trudeau dans ce
cas-là
mais avec un homme
remarquer qu'il va y avoir quatre
élections complémentaires une au Québec
ici dans Westmount Ville-Marie pour
remplacer Margaux une à Winnipeg pour
remplacer un ministre libéral et une
dans le Sud-Ouest
deux circonscriptions libérales qui sont
plus ou moins sûrs deux conservatrices
qui sont plus ou moins sûrs mais plutôt
sûr et qu'est-ce qu'on va surveiller des
batailles en conservateur
il y a eu tellement de bisbilles au
moment de l'investiture du candidat
conservateur que l'ancien député qui a
été député de mécanisé pendant 19 ans
a annoncé qu'il faisait campagne pour
les libéraux c'est quand même
remarquable le parti est en avant dans
un sondage il y a un nouveau chef et on
va voir quatre élections complémentaires
dont l'intérêt va être des batailles en
conservateur
c'est particulier c'est particulier ça
rend le travail de journaliste
particulièrement intéressant par contre
ça va être intéressant Alex Chantal
Michel c'est tout le temps qu'on a je
vous dis merci beaucoup à la semaine
prochaine